we are one week away from the harry and
meghan biography that is already
spilling
all sorts of royalty but i'm willing to
bet that this is the one day
that megan isn't thinking about it it's
been a very
stressful time for megan so it wouldn't
surprise me at all if she does actually
decide to just go on a road trip
possibly with oprah
and just getting some time out so what
are the chances of megan celebrating her
39th birthday with oprah in montecito
well oprah is working with harry on an
apple tv plus doc
and she gave archie his first birthday
present
hey look a duck that's not a duck that's
a rabbit
yeah can you turn the page i so enjoyed
having you here
for a month oprah also has room at the
mansion now the bestie gail king has
left and
we do know she takes quarantine very
seriously but that might not be a
problem
for h m i mean they've been at the house
that they're renting
ever since early march now they really
haven't been out much at all they
haven't seen their friends they
they've very much been in self-isolation
and on lockdown
but it's unlikely even oprah can shield
megan and harry from the backlash over
the new tell-all finding freedom claims
include
if she wanted the crown she'd have found
a way to make it hers
well there are claims in the book but
megan would often call paparazzi so that
she could be
photographed she would tip-down this off
with stories
she was very media savvy and that i'm
absolutely sure
and she wanted to go places she wanted
to be bigger than a b-list actress in
suits
while the entire royal family wished
megan a happy birthday on social today
it's still business as usual kate made
an appearance at a baby bank
delivering supplies for families in need
but reports claim
she has been left devastated by the
biography
and she's not the only one one of the
themes in the book
is that there were fears in the
corridors of power at buckingham palace
that megan and harry starr potentially
could eclipse william and kate but also
the future king
charles and camilla
you